Joe Biden riling up some folks over this
promise tweeting quote we're going to
beat Donald Trump and when we do we
won't just rebuild this nation will
transform it Jesse Joe Biden I think has
been in Washington DC for 47 years what
sort of transformation do you think he's
thinking about and no idea but I mean
this is where we are we're like we're
talking about one word that Biden said
the guy gives you so little to work with
that now we're doing a segment on a word
he used I'll go back to the well because
this is a great analogy I've used it
before let's talk about your
relationship with your significant other
would you ever say honey I want to
transform you
I want to radically transform your baby
how well do you think that would go over
not so well when you love something you
love the foundation of that thing the
conservatives like the foundation of
America what how it was built we want to
grow it we don't want to knock it down
and put things all over it and totally
transform it then there's the difference
Greg one of the things that Joe Biden
has said a few months ago is that he
would be a transitional president which
I think indicated he was just like
basically gonna be a caretaker for a
little bit but now he's promising a
transformation what do you think he
means I think that's very brave of him I
think it's time for a transitioned
candidate you know you I'm sure you've
heard of the phrase Dana all hat and no
cattle Joe is all spring and no puppet
he say he's he's he's he's happy to be
the vessel for the hard left it's all he
ever really wanted out of the office
it's not the work but the pop the
aviator glasses the lunches the bomber
jacket being able to shake hands and
sniff hair that's all he really wants to
do and he's right if he wins it also
gets the house in the Senate the world
will change because the left the
agitators the rioters they don't take no
or yes for an answer
they will not be deterred by winning
hardly they will actually turn to fire
up higher
because they know that people like Biden
and other people in the Democratic Party
are too scared of them so if you think
there's violence now and you think
there's racial strife and conflict and
hate and cancellation and banning and
burning imagine when Biden's in charge
the the left has tasted blood and they
like the taste of it and they know that
no one in the Democratic Party is gonna
take that meal away from him and one
Biden basically was able to pull out all
these wins in the primary to become the
de facto nominee by basically not
catering to the left but in this tweet
who is he talking to well it's almost
80% of Americans who say the country is
on the wrong track Dana that's Democrats
and Republicans people can see what's
going on and they want someone who goes
beyond status quo and says we're gonna
have a vision for how we can get the
economy going
raise wages how we can heal some of the
racial divide how we can deal with
health care and a meaningful way deal
with immigration in a meaningful way so
Biden is speaking to all that and the
idea that Biden is somebody's puppet
I mean Biden is a known in this town
he's been here 40 plus years in
government as a moderate and the idea
that he somehow now is a puppet of the
left the Bernie Sanders did well in
those primaries you mentioned because he
was to the far left of Joe Biden so I I
mean I think this is what Trump is
trying to push out and try to distort
reality for people but the polls show
most people aren't buying this
foolishness Emily I've been trying to
think about this about you know Biden
trying to bring these disparate parts of
the party together you've got the
progressives and you've got the
moderates more establishment like can he
pull that off while also talking is on
Twitter talking about transforming
America it seems like he's trying to
with this kind of language right he's
certainly appeasing the far left but
this is probably a turn-off for that
blue-collar Clinton Hadean faction that
he needs frankly in this upcoming
election so he definitely has to be
careful but I do have to point out I
don't understand
and why it's not so obvious the
hypocrisy if people say they want quote
transformation and yet they're willing
to vote for someone who has done nothing
apparently for 47 years examines point
of of referencing immigration and the
cartel strongholds health care school
systems etc all of that entrenched
systemic rot well I wouldn't call that
being bite in a moderate I would say
that's him being ineffective I like the
language there Emily pulling up the end
of that segment in a great way thank